get a rebound not one person crashed the
boards
alright let's reset the shot clock and
take a look at how the kid dunked
himself in this week's breakdown
[Music]
you never see rich people with
trampolines it's like an above-ground
pool it's just not an upscale piece of
lawn furniture hey at least they sprung
for the safety net what could go wrong
well here's one thing that could go
wrong the kids could start
double-bouncing out of each other for
those of you who don't know what a
double bounce says it's the trampoline
equivalent of a speed ball for those of
you who don't know what a speedball is
its what killed John Belushi for those
of you who don't know who John Belushi
is he's Jim Belushi's brother for those
of you who don't know who Jim is he's
the guy from according to Jim for those
of you who didn't watch according to Jim
congratulations oh wow is he up there
somebody just caught fire NBA Jam style
savor the moment Scotty Skiles because
it's about to turn sour that's a
technical foul get off the rim yes suck
it Vince Carter dangling by your elbow
doesn't seem like such a big deal
anymore it hurts to hear this is where
he and his torn ACL could learn a lesson
from Sasha just distribute the ball set
some screens and draw defenders out of
lane so real players can put on a show
and why is he crying like Nancy Kerrigan
you're right you don't get to dunk and I
hate to point this out but the black guy
is running away
and who can blame him nothing good has
ever come from a black guy standing over
a crying white kid hey at least the
camera guy was able to stop laughing
long enough to put this SportsCenter
highlight online and for that we thank
you
[Music]